miguel registró cuantas horas dormía
durante 50 días e hizo un programa de
los resultados que intervalo contiene la
mediana de su cantidad de sueño y no se
están preguntando en qué intervalo del
histograma será este de 6 a 6.5 o
este-oeste o cualquiera de estos cuál de
estos intervalos contiene la mediana
pausa del vídeo y traten de resolverlo
muy bien vamos a resolver esto juntos
déjenme recordarles como encontramos la
mediana sí tengo los datos 11 9 7 3 y 2
la forma de encontrar la mediana es
ordenando los datos de menor a mayor en
realidad podríamos hacerlo de mayor a
menor pero hagámoslo de menor a mayor 2
7 9 11 y la mediana es el número que
tenemos en medio y tengo un número medio
claro porque tengo 5 datos si tuviera un
número par de datos
los ordenaría de menor a mayor digamos
que tengo un 1 1 3 y 7 aquí no tengo un
número medio claro de modo que la
mediana será la media de los dos números
de enmedio entonces en esta situación
miguel tiene un número par de datos así
que la mediana va a ser igual a la media
del 25º y 26º dato estos son los dos
datos de enmedio entonces qué intervalo
contiene el vigésimo quinto y el
vigésimo sexto dato bueno podemos
empezar por abajo en realidad podemos
ver cada intervalo y pensar cuántos
datos tiene este tiene 2 este tiene 9
este tiene 12 simplemente estoy leyendo
cuántos datos hay en cada uno de estos
intervalos este tiene 12 este tiene 11
lo podemos ver aquí este tiene 2 y este
tiene 2
vemos este tenemos los dos datos menores
si vemos los dos intervalos menores
combinados tenemos los once menores si
vemos los tres intervalos menores
tenemos 11 + 12 tenemos los 23 menores
entonces aquí tenemos los 23 datos
menores de modo que el vigésimo cuarto
vigésimo quinto vigésimo sexto dato los
siguientes doce datos empezando del
menor van a estar en este intervalo que
tenemos aquí y nos importan los 25º y
26º datos así que estos datos
definitivamente van a estar en este
intervalo de 7.5 a 8 horas de sueño
hasta el próximo vídeo